- All right y'all, I'm back with
Jason Derulo and Nicole Byer!
(audience cheers)
And we're helping Emily who
says she's unlucky in love
and finds all the wrong prospects online.
Well, today things are gonna change.
We're trying a new approach
with Emily, all right?
She's borrowing my chair from "The Voice"
to pick her next man.
She'll have no idea
what the guys look like
because this chair forces you to listen.
This is "Blind Dating".
(audience cheers)
All right, let's meet the guys.
All right, so go ahead guys,
y'all introduce yourselves.
- Hi everybody, my name is Tim, hi Emily.
- Hello.
- I come from a small farm town
called Almont, Michigan but,
I live out here in Los Angeles
as a independent film maker.
- [Kelly] Awesome, okay!
(audience applause)
- Hi Emily, I'm Nick.
I'm from Miami, Florida, I
speak five languages, French,
Portuguese, Spanish, German.
- Oh my gosh, slacker!
(audience applause)
So, here's how this is gonna go.
Tim and Nick will take turns talking.
Just like in "The Voice", if
Emily hears something she likes
she'll hit the button.
The chair will turn and that
will be the man she chooses.
While she can hit the button at any time,
it doesn't mean she should.
(laughter)
This works better with
just a little patience,
let's get started.
Tim and Nick, what is your
idea of a perfect date?
- Well, my idea of a perfect
date actually involves
the happiest place of Earth, Disneyland.
(audience cheers)
I think you get to know
a lot about a person
by their favorite character and
also what rides they choose.
- Yes.
- So, we would start of the day
by walking down Main Street,
maybe sharing a churro,
some ice cream maybe,
and then we would have
a reservation for two
at one of their five star restaurants,
and then finish off the evening
with a beautiful firework
show at Cinderella's Castle.
- All right, he knows what's
happening there, all right.
Panel, what do you guys think?
- No, no!
- No?
- No!
That's too magical, the second
date is what, in a dumpster?
(laughter)
You can only go down from there.
- [Kelly] It's gonna go down from there.
- But, I also feel like the
answer was a little like,
let me give her what she wants.
- No, no, no, I will tell you this.
I read things they were gonna
say before they got here,
he actually had that in his
thing before he came here.
- Oh!
- What, wow!
- He actually had that, that was not
because he heard us talking.
- I thought the same thing.
- You thought that too?
- I kinda did, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, no.
- I'm glad we cleared that up.
- All right, good job.
- All right, so Nick,
what's your perfect date?
- Well, I would be taking you
to the second happiest place
on Earth, Runyon Canyon.
We'd go hiking 'cause I'm very adventurous
and we'd go up to the top, right?
Get to know each other a little bit.
See the sunset, watch the LA lights,
and I'd take you to my favorite
Michelin star restaurant.
- All right, all right.
- Damn, okay, they got money!
- That's two dates in one!
- [Nicole] That's money!
- [Jason] That's spending
the whole day together
A day date.
- What do you think
about hiking on the first date guys?
- I'm not going hiking,
you can't get to know me
while I'm huffing and puffing.
(laughter)
- [Kelly] Actually, I'm like
so in, I'm easy to please.
I'm like, that sounds fun.
- No.
- Yeah, you know though,
you know I like about it,
if you like me sweaty and
gross, then you're in.
- Yeah.
- You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, I'm showing you the worst.
(audience applause)
- [Jason] No, I like that
one, I like that one.
- All right, well you like
working out, so, yeah.
- Yeah, I do.
- All right, well great job guys.
You haven't hit the button, Emily.
Yeah, you're, okay, okay good.
Let's ramp things up.
- I'm being patient.
- You know I believe in the magic of song.
And this is my "Voice" chair,
so I just embarrass these men.
(laughter)
So, I asked Tim and Nick to pen
they're very own love ballads.
All right guys, it's all on you.
Emily, you hit the button if you feel it.
But, maybe listen to both songs, okay.
(upbeat country music)
- Okay Emily, here we go.
Put a little country in
ya, for a little bit.
♪ Baby don't be scared
'cause I'm scared too ♪
♪ I know love has burned
you a time or two ♪
♪ And all that I ask is
for a single chance ♪
♪ To show you how love really feels ♪
- All right, all right, Tim that was cute.
That was really good, I like the country,
I like the soul in it, but check this out.
(upbeat latin music)
♪ So you're looking for
love on Kelly's show ♪
♪ Love to be a Latino you get to know ♪
♪ So trust me when I say
(sings in foreign language) ♪
♪ Learn some Spanish ♪
♪ I'd love to teach ya ♪
(audience cheers)
- Come on Tim!
- I didn't really feel
the heart in that one,
I really didn't feel the heart in that one
♪ It can be so blind but
with your hand in mine ♪
♪ I know everything will be just fine ♪
♪ And your back's turned to me ♪
♪ Girl it's harder to see ♪
♪ That beautiful smile I
ain't seen in a while ♪
(audience cheers)
- You chose Tim!
I think it was Disneyland.
Y'all come here.
Okay, I think I know what it was.
It was Disneyland.
- I know, it was.
- It was Disneyland.
- Yeah.
- All right, so Emily,
what made you choose him
over the other guy.
- I would say, obviously
the Disneyland got me.
You really knew all
those parts of the park,
so that's always encouraging.
The churro, I like churros,
and the country twang,
I could sense a Midwest, Southern feel.
- Yeah!
- But that's why.
- All right, all right.
Well big thanks to Nick,
we wish you the best.
- Thank you!
- [Kelly] Congrats to Emily and Tim!